- [Voiceover] Hey everyone.
So in the last video I introduced
this thing called the second
partial derivative test,
and if you have some kind
of multivariable function
or really just a two variable function
is what this applies to, something that's
f of x, y and it outputs a number.
When you're looking
for places where it has
a local maximum or a local
minimum, the first step,
as I talked about a few videos ago,
is to find where the gradient equals zero
and sometimes you'll hear these called
critical points or stable points,
but inputs where the gradient equals zero
and that's really just a way of compactly
writing the fact that all the partial
derivatives are equal to zero.
Now when you find a point like this,
in order to test whether
it's a local maximum
or a local minimum or a saddle point
without actually looking at the graph,
'cause you don't always have the ability
to do that at your
disposal, the first step
is to compute this long value,
and this is the thing I
wanna give intuition behind.
Where you take all three
second partial derivatives,
the second partial
derivative with respect to x,
derivative with respect to y
and the mixed partial derivative
where first you do it with respect to x,
then you do it with respect to y.
And you compute this
value where you evaluate
each one of those at your critical point
and you multiply the two pure
second partial derivatives
and then subtract off the square
of the mixed partial derivative
and again, I'll give intuition
for that in a reason,
but right now we just kinda take it,
oh, alright, I guess
you compute this number
and if that value H, if that value H
is greater than zero, what it tells you,
what it tells you is
that you definitely have
either a maximum or a minimum.
So you definitely have either
a maximum or a minimum.
And then to determine which one
you just have to look at the
concavity in one direction.
So you'll look at the
second partial derivative
with respect to x for example,
and if that was positive
that would tell you
when you look in the x direction
there's a positive
concavity, if it was negative
it would mean a negative concavity.
And so that means a positive value
for that second partial derivative
would mean a local minimum
and a negative value
would mean a local maximum.
So that's what it means if this value H
turns out to be greater than zero.
And if this value H turns
out to be less than zero,
strictly less than zero,
then you definitely
have a saddle point, saddle point.
Which is neither a maximum, nor a minimum.
It's kind of like there's disagreement
in different directions over whether
it should be a maximum or a minimum.
And if H equals zero, the
test isn't good enough.
You would have to do something
else to figure it out.
So why does this work?
Why does this seemingly
random conglomeration
of second partial
derivatives give you a test
that let's you determine what type
of stable point you're looking at?
Well let's just understand
each term individually.
So this second partial
derivative with respect to x,
since you're taking
both partial derivatives
with respect to x,
you're basically treating
the entire multivariable function as if x
is the only variable and
y was just some constant.
So it's like you're only looking at
movement in the x direction.
So in terms of a graph,
let's say we've got like,
this graph here, you
can imagine slicing this
with a plane that represents movement
purely in the x direction, so that'll be
a constant y value slice,
and you take a look
at the curve where this
slice intersects your graph.
And in the one that I have pictured here
it looks like it's a positive concavity.
So this term right here kind
of tells you x concavity.
So it's kind of like the,
what is the concavity
as far as the variable x is concerned.
And then symmetrically, this over here,
when you take the partial derivative
with respect to y two times in a row,
it's like you're ignoring the fact
that x is even a variable
and you're looking
purely at what movement in
the y direction looks like.
Which on the graph that
I have pictured here,
also happens to give you kind of this
positive concavity parabola look,
but the point is that
the curve on the graph
that results from looking at movement
purely in the y direction can be analyzed
just looking at this partial derivative
with respect to y twice in a row.
So that term kind of tells
you y concavity, y concavity.
Now first of all, notice what happens
if these disagree.
If say, x thought there
should be positive concavity
and y thought there should
be negative concavity.
Here, I'll write that
down, what that means.
If x thinks there's positive concavity
we have here some kind of positive number
that I'll just write as like,
a plus sign in parenthesis.
And then this here, y concavity, would be
some kind of negative number,
so we'll just put like,
a negative sign in parenthesis.
So that would mean this very first term
would be a positive times a negative
and that first term would be negative.
And now the thing that
we're subtracting off,
I'll get to the intuition behind this
mixed partial derivative term in a moment,
but for now you can notice
that it's something squared,
it's something that's
always a positive term.
So you're always subtracting
off a positive term
which means if this
initial one is negative,
the entire term H is
definitely gonna be negative,
so it's gonna put you over into
this saddle point territory.
Which makes sense,
because if the x direction
and the y direction disagree on concavity
that should be a saddle point.
The quintessential example here
is when you have the function f of x, y
is equal to x squared minus y squared,
x squared minus y squared.
And the graph of that, by the way,
the graph of that would look like this
where, let's see, so
orienting myself here,
moving in the x direction
you have kind of,
positive concavity which corresponds
to the positive coefficient
in front of x squared,
and in the y direction it
looks like negative concavity.
Corresponding to that negative coefficient
in front of the y squared.
So when there's disagreement among these,
the test ensures that we're
gonna have a saddle point.
Now what about if they agree, right,
what if either it's the case that x thinks
there should be positive concavity
and y thinks there should
be positive concavity,
or they both agree that there should be,
you know, negative concavity.
In either one of these cases,
when you multiply them
together they're positive.
So it's kind of like saying, if you look
purely in the x direction or
purely in the y direction,
they agree, that there
should be, you know,
definitely positive concavity
or definitely negative concavity.
So that entire first term
is going to be positive.
So it's kind of like a clever way
of capturing whether
or not the x directions
and y directions agree.
However, the reason that it's not enough
is 'cause in either case we're still
subtracting off something
that's always a positive term.
So when you have this agreement
between the x dicretion
and the y direction
it then turns into a battle between
this x, y agreement
and whatever's going on
with this mixed partial derivative term.
And the stronger that mixed
partial derivative term,
the bigger this negative number,
so the more it's pulling the entire value
H towards being negative.
So let me see if I can give a little
bit of reasoning behind why this
mixed partial derivative term is trying
to pull things towards
being a saddle point.
Let's take a look at
the very simple function
f of x, y, is equal to x times y.
So what that looks like graphically,
f of x, y equal x times y, is this.
It looks like a saddle point.
So let's go ahead and look
at it's partial derivatives.
So the first partial derivatives,
partial with respect to x and partial
with respect to y, well when you do it
with respect to x, x
looks like a variable,
y looks like a constant,
it's just that constant y.
And when you do it with respect to y
it goes the other way around.
Y looks like the variable,
x looks like the constant
so the derivative is that constant x.
Now when you take the
second partial derivatives,
if you do it with respect
to x twice in a row
you're differentiating
this with respect to x,
that looks like a
constant, so you get zero.
And similarly, if you
do it with respect to y
twice in a row, you're doing this
and the derivative of x with respect to y,
x looks like a constant, goes to zero.
But the important term, the one that we're
getting an intuition about here,
this mixed partial derivative,
first with respect to x
then with respect to y, well
you can view it in two ways.
Either you take the
derivative of this expression
with respect to y, in which case it's one,
or you think of taking the
derivative of this expression
with respect to x, in
which case it's also one.
So it's kind of like this
function is a very pure
way to take a look at what this
mixed partial derivative term looks like.
And the higher the coefficient here,
if I had put a coefficient
of, you know, three here
that would mean that the
mixed partial derivative
would ultimately end up being three.
So notice, the reason that
this looks like a saddle
isn't because the x and
y directions disagree,
in fact if you take a
look at pure movement
in the x direction it just
looks like a constant.
The height of the graph along this plane,
along this line here is just a constant
which corresponds to the fact that the
second partial derivative
with respect to x
is equal to zero.
And then likewise, if
you cut it with a plane
representing a constant x value,
meaning movement purely
in the y direction,
the height of the graph doesn't
really change along there,
it's constantly zero which corresponds
to the fact that this other
partial derivative is zero.
The reason that the whole
thing looks like a saddle
is 'cause when you cut it
with a diagonal plane here,
a diagonal plane, it looks
like it has negative concavity.
But if you were to chop it,
you know, in another direction
it would look like it
has positive concavity.
So in fact, this xy term
is kind of like a way
of capturing whether there's disagreement
in the diagonal directions.
And one thing that might
be surprising at first
is that you only need one of these
second partial derivatives in order
to determine all of the information
about the diagonal directions.
'Cause you can imagine,
you know, maybe there's
disagreement between movement
along one certain vector
and movement along
another and you would have
to account for infinitely many directions
and look at all of them.
And yet evidently, it's
the case that you only
really need to take a look at this
mixed partial derivative term.
You know, along with the original pure
second partial derivatives with respect
to x twice and with respect to y twice.
But still, looking at
only three different terms
to take into account possible disagreement
in infinitely many directions actually
feels like quite the surprise.
And if you want the full,
rigorous justification
for why this is the case, why this
second partial derivative test works
and kind of, an airtight argument.
I've put that in an
article that you can find
that kind of, goes into the dirty details
for those who are interested.
But if you just want the intuition,
I think it's fine to think about
the fact that this
mixed partial derivative
is telling you how much your function
looks like the graph of f
of x, y equal x times y.
Which is the graph that kind of captures
all of the diagonal disagreement.
And then when you let that term,
that mixed partial derivative term,
kind of compete with the agreement
between the x and y directions,
you know, if they agree very strongly,
you have to subtract
off a very strong amount
in order to pull it
back to being negative.
So this battle back and
forth, if it's pulled
to be very negative that
will give you a saddle point,
if it doesn't pull hard
enough, then the agreement
between the x and y directions wins out
and it's either a local
maximum or a local minimum.
So hopefully that sheds
a little bit of light
on why this term makes sense
and why it's a reasonable way
to combine the three different
second partial derivatives
available to you, and
again, if you want the full
details, I've written that
up in an article form.
I'll see you next video.